hi I'm Matt and I'm wondering is Buzz
seeds favorite couple Merlot Neil and
Aria and Vaughn faking it let's talk
about it right now since I was a child
I've been naturally inquisitive
questioning anything and everything that
didn't quite make sense as I grew I
poured countless hours into a number of
conspiracy theories some of these
theories I believe in some of these
theories they don't but some of them I
do here I'll be studying the evidence
for and against all of history's
mysteries doing the work so you don't
have to but you really should do it on
your own like check sources and all that
okay on today's episode okay so you
might have a couple thoughts thoughts
like leave them alone who cares why are
you doing this to which I respectively
answer no me and because I'm being paid
to let's just say I'm being hired by a
private party to use my investigative
skills to crack this case wide open and
finally get to the bottom of it
so where do we start maybe with the
relationship in general perhaps you've
already heard the story
hi i'm aria
i'm a production assistant in 2017 i met
an enterprising young intern at BuzzFeed
named Ari in Sivan but there was
something about him that didn't appear
and wouldn't appear immediately he was
devious at first I think we all just
thought he was nice maybe overly eager
that was kind of his thing a nice guy
but maybe a little too nice when finally
hired he spent much of 2018 making the
most sensational videos you could
imagine I tried to sell myself in Turkey
I married a stranger in Vegas and a
bunch of videos of porn stars like a
like a bunch of videos of porn stars he
knew how to make a hit and it would
appear that he would stop at nothing to
do so in 2019 Merle moved from New York
to Los Angeles for work and seemed to be
enjoying the single life it's also worth
mentioning that it's well documented
that Merle said she wanted to stay
single for at least a whole year aria
however was looking for love and quite
possibly desperate the story at this
point as they'd have you believe is that
they didn't started a message back and
forth about work stuff eventually
hitting it off and at some point
messaging about non work stuff things
progressed they started to be in every
video together and then BAM
how I fell in love with a co-worker in
January 2020 I thought the video might
have been about me
and upon watching and found out it
wasn't anyway they lived happily ever
after I don't know that's the story as
you know it or as we've been told but
maybe it's not the whole truth
I along with the lovely YouTube
commenters have compiled a couple of
theories that might actually be the case
remember when I said that Aria knows how
to make a sensational video well I mean
it in the best and worst way possible
the things I've seen this man do four
hits I've been behind the camera with
him for a lot of it
however the trust we built together was
dashed in September 2019 with the
release of I faked being at work for a
week a video in which he painstakingly
faked a presence in LA and lied to his
friends while he was actually in Europe
I bring this video up for two reasons
number one he will do anything for a
video number two he's lied to me before
and he may be doing it now it's also
worth noting that while he was lying to
everybody for this video one of the only
people he trusted to keep his secret was
Merle could this be another sick prank
on me their friend and you the wonderful
viewer may be famous fake Hollywood
couples pop up all the time I don't want
to be sued so I won't name any but it's
not out of the realm of possibility
sometimes it's for business sometimes
it's to construct a narrative and
sometimes like maybe in the case of Rin
Merle they do it for the clown whether
you believe that they're in love or not
there's absolutely no disputing that
their follower counts have skyrocketed
look I feel girls talking about it too
but when you're taking down the
Charlatans you gotta follow the money or
in this case a different kind of
currency now this one is purely from the
commenters not me but some people
believe that REM Merle and BuzzFeed got
in a room drew up a contract and
manufactured one of America's greatest
love stories for the record I don't
think this is true
BuzzFeed Incorporated has been nothing
but good to me as a director and
producer I think the only influence that
the company has had on the couple has
been placing them on a team together
constructing a seating chart that sat
them next to each other and then putting
them in a video after video for a
calendar year
but it's important to mention if any of
these theories are true there could be
little to if any consequences so I
wanted to do the right investigation so
I made a couple phone calls to those
closest to the couple Rachel Merle's
best friend Fernando
Arya's best friend and Jack R is camera
man hello is this Rachel yes hi is this
jack sure is I guess I know that because
your phone number is in my phone I don't
know maybe when we went to area 51 we
have to go see what it is no we don't we
don't have to see what it is doing a lot
of research on Merliah are you familiar
for real
so the first theory we have is that this
is another fake video what do you think
I think he is crazy and would totally do
something like this I know we'll do
anything there's been video ideas he's
had that have gotten shot down from
BuzzFeed and others like a year he's
trained for four months yeah he's
capable
it's the biggest con of all time and I
think that's the most attractive thing
to are well the second theory is that
it's all for the followers baby
yes fake relationship when one time I
did it back in 2009 you had a fake
relationship with I don't forgot that
characters name it was messy at the end
it was like maybe the first two seasons
of the show should definitely go do some
research on that I don't think I will
anytime you guys are hanging out any
time anyone they mentioned oh look at
how many followers we've gotten out of
this and then like maybe high five or
something like that
we know people who might do this for
followers but are they them I don't
think either crazy for the followers I
feel like they're both pretty humble
about their followers they like having
followers it just kind of happened to be
that they start dating and people were
really invested in the relationship the
third and final theory BuzzFeed has
contractually obligated them to be are
in a relationship
series bad I don't think ever there
would be you like cyclists and do this
but I think they'll be like oh my god
this would be so cool you guys should
totally do this and then there's some
type of like unspoken pressure to do it
so Rachel you're saying you don't think
it's fake at all I'm saying I know it's
not fake it's fully does that every time
that's kind of weird
yeah no but they're both so great
together
I love them together and I don't think
I'll ever break up because I think they
are a perfect match and I do believe
that maybe they're just young kids
having a good time yeah and it's all
gravy baby absolutely and if it comes
with some extra fall or some money okay
well there you have it it being
something more to think about but where
does that leave us are we any closer to
understanding the mystery of Merliah are
they just a couple of cute kids who
found a way to make their romance work
for them or are they part of a more
sinister plot intent on pulling the
collective wool over your and my eyes
I think perhaps maybe a million YouTube
commenters before we might have said it
best it's none of our business
and once this check clears it'll
literally be none of my business
and now return to reveling in the fact
that my friends who both deserve someone
who deeply cares for them and shares
their common interests seem happy
congratulations
I will say though if this is a prank
Aria I've been told that I can't legally
threaten to kill you but we won't be
friends anymore probably okay